- [Theme Voice] Bricklberry!
(dramatic jingle)
- Who's that?
- One of your co-workers
if you make it.
You'll be seeing her every day.
- [Group Of Men] Me first, me!
(dramatic jingle)
- Guinness, I just
broke a record.
I stuck 39 rolls
of dimes up my ass.
What?
Shia LaBeouf did 40?
(coin drop)
Damn it!
(dramatic jingle)
- [Announcer] Connie is 12
hands high with good gums,
and apparently, has
broken our scale.
- Connie, where's
your bikini bottom?
- It's right here, my
camel toe's eating it.
See?
(slap noise)
- [Man With Mustache] Ah!
- [Woman In Blue] Eww!
(dramatic jingle)
(erotic grunting)
- [Man] Inaudible.
(dramatic jingle)
(smacking sound effects)
(farting noise)
(screaming)
(dramatic jingle)
- You are beautiful from
head to toe, to camel toe.
- Thanks, I can pick
up a pencil with it.
Wanna see?
- [Man] Nope, that's okay!
(dramatic jingle)
- I don't know who Semen is,
but I'm eating his yogurt.
(moaning delightfully)
- It's got a kick to it.
- Steve, what the
(bleep) are you doing?
- I know, I'm
cheating on my diet.
- Cheatin' on your diet,
you eatin' bear jizz.
- Oh my God!
(barf sound)
(dramatic jingle)
- Oh good job Ethel,
now I'm stuck.
- Brace yourself.
One!
Two!
Three!
(loud farting noise)
- Ah, I feel much better now.
Strangely enough, I
kind of enjoyed that.
- It's
in
every
hole.
(dramatic jingle)
- But there's one
gaping hole you missed.
(dramatic crash)
- [Man With Mustache] Hey,
what the hell is that?
- You don't like it?
(dramatic crash)
- No, it looks like someone
spilled a can of ravioli!
- Okay, I...
(dramatic crash)
- [Man With Mustache] It
looks like the Elephant Man
after a pie eating contest!
- You done?
(dramatic crash)
- [Man With Mustache] No,
it looks like a Bangladeshi
street vendor flipped
over his food cart!
- [Theme Voice] Brickleberry!